yet secretary blinken insisted today the
u.s withdrawal from afghanistan was an
extraordinary success blinken was
grilled by republicans on the house
foreign affairs committee this afternoon
that grilling has continued late into
the day congressional correspondent
aisha hosni starts us off tonight live
from capitol hill good evening aisha
good evening to you democrats tore into
republican questioning tonight as
republicans tore into blinkin's decision
making calling for him to resign at one
point and even questioning why he didn't
show up to this hearing in person
can you tell us where you are today
yes i'm at the state department i
couldn't couldn't be bothered to come
down here and see congress all right
that's great the first oversight hearing
over the chaotic withdrawal of
afghanistan got off to a contentious
start as members of the house foreign
affairs committee grilled secretary of
state anthony blinken questions range
from the basic how many americans and
afghan allies are still left as of the
end of last week
we had about
100 american citizens in afghanistan who
told us that they wish to leave the
country to concerns about the nation's
current dealings with the taliban are
you negotiating with the taliban on the
issue of
legitimizing them
as it a real government what we expect
and will insist on from the taliban uh
if they
want to seek any legitimacy or any
support and that includes it starts with
freedom of travel the last time blinken
testified before the house committee in
june he told them the u.s was not
withdrawing the embassy was staying and
this if there is a significant
deterioration in security i don't think
it's going to be something that happens
from a friday to a monday today blinken
made clear the administration does not
support the current taliban government
the interim government named by the
taliban
falls very short of the mark that was
set by the international community
for inclusivity
democrat frustration over the
evacuations has been bubbling over in
recent days but today several of them
gave blinken an opening to address what
this administration inherited from the
previous administration how meticulous
was the planning for the trump
administration declared may 1st
withdrawal thank you congressman we
inherited a deadline we did not inherit
a plan
what remains to be seen is what
accountability may come from today's and
any future hearings republican committee
member brian mast told fox he's not
holding his breath i think they're too
arrogant to resign they don't see as
though there's any problems that they
created on the globe or domestically or
anywhere else
now brett blinken will appear in person
tomorrow for the senate foreign
relations committee hearing tomorrow
morning
in which some democrat senators have
already indicated that they want to
focus primarily on the last 20 years as
opposed to
the days in august during that draw down
and with senator murphy also adding this
that he hopes republicans don't quote
make this turn this into a circus brett
aisha housing live on capitol hill i
should thanks hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else